[Music]
all right so in the left's latest Trump
Witch Hunt radical New York attorney
general Leticia James who campaigned on
going after one man Donald Trump one
family the Trump family one organization
the Trump organization is now claiming
that the Trump organization in fact
inflated the value of its assets and
what is a big fraud scheme now at the
center of this trial is an insane ruling
from a judge claiming that Mara Lago in
Palm Beach that its real value is only
$18 million all right let's do a quick
oneone on Palm Beach real estate look at
this here we got a 2 acre wooded lot on
the ocean there's no building on it at
all 5 minutes away from Mara Lago listed
for a whopping
$150 million you got another empty lot
nearby 2.3 Acres on the ocean listed for
200 million look at your screen maral
Lago is a 60,000 Square ft
58 uh bedroom 33 bom Mansion historical
location as such with two clubs located
on 20 acres of prime Palm Beach real
estate with a unique position in that it
has property on the interner coastal
side and on the ocean from side with a
club associated with it 20 acres
okay now this is what the judge wants
you to believe is worth uh let's see
over $100 million less than a wooded lot
of two acres you got to be kidding me
now remember every contract that the
Trump family was involved in with real
estate and applying for loans and
dealing with insurance companies lending
companies okay they would tell they had
language in this contract that said not
to use their appraisals but they had to
use their own appraisals that it would
be their fiduciary responsibility to
come up with what they believe the real
value of a property happens to be uh and
by the way not One Bank not one
insurance company ever filed any
complaint everyone was paid on time now
if this isn't you know hypocritical
left-wing politics that is worse I don't
know what is here with reaction Trump
legal spokesperson Alina H is with us
the author of The Constitution of the US
and other patrio uh patriotic documents
Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett now
Elina I don't want to put you in a
position I understand a gag order is in
place but I do want to talk about real
estate down in Palm Beach I know a thing
or two about it and I've talked to a a
lot of Realtors They're laughing at this
so the allegation is that the Trump
organization was artificially inflating
numbers to get more favorable loan terms
and more favorable Insurance uh rates
okay the judge is claiming that a
property according to Realtors I spoke
to is kind of close to a billion dollars
and he's sticking with1 18 million now
doesn't that make him guilty of the very
thing that they're trying to claim that
the Trump family
did it does and I think that we should
look at anybody that's taken a property
and their tax assessed value which is by
the way what he thinks the property is
now worth the $18 million is a tax
assessed value so if you actually were
going to sell it and I know you're
familiar with the property so am I you
probably could maybe sell half of a
tennis court here for $18 million given
where it's located and what it's worth
the statement of financial condition for
the president for the company was
undervalued tremendously if the
president had put his brand alone the
brand of trump which got him elected to
off office that brand alone would
quadruple triple double whatever the
number is the statement of financial
condition this is insanity and the fact
frankly that I I can't speak freely is
insanity in it and of itself so um we're
really in a Banana Republic this is
political lawfare not Warfare and I'm
sitting front row for it it's
unfortunate so Greg Jared just common
sense and logic needs to Prevail here so
you got 20 plus acres on the inner Coast
and on the ocean side you got a club you
got this ma massive building it's
historical uh many many bedrooms and
bathrooms and everything in between and
it's a club on top of it and meanwhile a
2 acre parcel of ocean P property in
Palm Beach is going to go for 200
million but that 20 plus acre property
is only worth $18 million and the judge
is sticking by um uh that valuation with
a straight face you got to be kidding me
I mean th this can't
be this really can't be happening in
this country but it is happening what do
you make of it
all well it shows how bias the judge is
determined to find the trumps liable at
trial but the good news for them is Sean
I doubt that any of this will ever stand
up on appeal because this executive law
being used against them completely
undermines More Than A Century of
established common law that requires
proof of intent to deceive in civil
fraud cases that somebody knowingly made
false statements but you know this
poorly conceived law simply does away
with all of that and punishes somebody
for making inaccurate statements with no
intent to do so sort of like Prosecuting
a customer for robbing a bank because
the teller gave out the wrong change
this law also o violates the
Constitution Sean it penalizes
inaccurate commercial speech which the
first amendment protects but you know
under Leticia James anybody can have
their business taken away from them by
her if they happen to misstate without
negligence or intent assets that are
used to secure loans even if the
business owner relied entirely on
professionals to do the valuations which
the Trump organization did I I'm not
sure whether Alina can answer or not and
I don't want to put her in a bad spot
here but you do have an AG that ran on a
platform to go after one man Donald
Trump one family the Trump family one
organization the Trump
organization um Alina to the extent you
can you can weigh in Greg you can weigh
in you know to me there's something so
fundamentally wrong about that running
on a campaign and now fulfilling a
campaign promise alinaa
that's 100% wrong it's political
interference it's per political
persecution prosecution and it is
something we've been fighting and I'm
happy to speak freely about it Miss
James has gone outside and showed up
Shan only on the days where it was
headline days only on the days where the
president is there where the kids were
there she wasn't there for the past few
days she thought they were mundane
evidently but the other day she's
sitting there while the city is going to
hell and we are watching something where
the statement of Financial condition was
frankly undervalued where there was you
know a disclaimer on the front page with
sophisticated lenders saying you need to
do your own due diligence but nobody is
paying attention to the glaring fact
that you just brought up Miss James is
doing this for political reasons she
does not care about New York she does
not care about businesses doing well she
is doing it so that she can make money
so that she can run and you know what
frankly it's backfiring in her face if
you look at the polls you know and you
got to think about this is the state
Greg and we only have about 20 seconds
left that has no bail laws not one
insurance company that I've heard of or
read about not One Lending institution
none of them complained why why is this
even in
court when when she ran for office on
the campaign promise of quote unquote
getting Trump she was violating the
ethical standard that governs prosecutor
she had no access to any evidence any
investigative files she committed
herself publicly to getting a specific
individual and then she misused the
power of her office to manufacture a
case against him that's the sort of
thing for which she should be disbarred
we're now criminalizing political
differences that's a very dangerous
place for any country to be all right
thank you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else